with no second debate between trump and
biden each candidate does a town hall
with network news savannah guthrie earns
a job in the biden white house and
fallout continues over social media's
decision to weaponize on joe biden's
behalf i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights take
action at expressvpn.com
well if you've been watching what's
going on with social media you might be
thinking to yourself
should those people have my data the
answer is of course those people should
not have your data
the fact is they monetize your data and
hackers can grab your data online this
is why you need
expressvpn it's why i work with
expressvpn
all of those giant tech services they
can sell information to ad companies
tech giants can use your data to target
you expressvpn stops all of this
they create a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet so
your online activity cannot be seen by
anyone
i use expressvpn myself on all my
devices it works on everything phones
laptops even routers so everyone who
shares your wi-fi can still be protected
even if they don't have express vpn
here's the best part using expressvpn
it's as easy as closing the bathroom
door you just fire up the app you click
one button and you are now
protected so if you're like me you
believe that your online activity is
your business
if you have serious trust issues with
big tech as i think you should at this
point
secure yourself by visiting
expressvpn.com ben
today use my exclusive link
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
you can get you can get an extra three
months for free that's
dot com expressvpn.com ben wants more
exp our essvpn.com
ben alrighty so last night we had two
dueling town halls is where you cue
dueling banjos because that's basically
what it was on one side you had joe
biden
being treated to a massage from george
stepanopoulos and on the other
you had what appeared to be some sort of
sadistic ritual
happening in which savannah guthrie
basically whipped donald trump over and
over and over
and asked him to shout may i have
another i mean that was pretty much the
dueling perspective
like you knew this is what was going to
happen and this is the big problem with
the media now listen
does savannah guthrie have every right
to go after trump and ask him tough
questions of course
but the problem is that george
stephanopoulos does not go after joe
biden and ask him tough questions so
here is the deal either
either everyone ought to get grilled or
no one ought to get grilled either riots
have an infomercial for joe biden
and an infomercial for donald trump or
we got to have a grilling for joe biden
and a grilling for donald trump but
every single person who works in network
news
is going to vote for joe biden and so
they probably couldn't even identify
anyone who's willing to show up and ask
a tough question of joe biden the
scandal here really is not savannah
guthrie's treatment of trump
although it was egregious and a lot of
her questions i thought were were
poorly handled i thought a lot of her
questions were simply bad or irrelevant
the real scandal is that no one will ask
joe biden a tough question or a
follow-up tough question
when he makes a stupid statement no one
and he won't appear with anybody
who will and this is all considered
totally fine and totally okay
again it can be grillings for all or
grillings for none what you can't have
is in the famous phrase of the simpsons
abortions for some in american flags for
others
like that's not the way this works you
don't get to as a media proclaim that
you're objective
and then treat the two candidates in
polar opposite ways
so the lead up to all of this was again
demonstrative of the bias that
is latent and actually in many cases
open
in the mainstream media remember that
there was supposed to be a debate last
night between biden
and trump which trump frankly needs
because trump needs to be able to ask
biden questions that moderators simply
will not ask
joe biden or follow up on well that
debate got cancelled specifically last
week
because donald trump came down with
kovid it was done without any medical
input
it was done without any medical advice
it was done a week in advance of the
debate
it made no sense at all we pointed this
out at the time it mainly appeared like
the
commission on presidential debate
panicked and like they wanted to give an
excuse
for the debate not to happen and so they
cancelled it in advance
barring some sort of zoom debate and
trump said i'm not doing a zoom debate
because joe biden's going to read off a
teleprompter and also it allows you to
mute me
and it totally kills the dynamics i'm
not going to do that and the commission
on presidential debate said
well we take kovid seriously okay so you
end up last night
with two in-person town halls so why
couldn't they have just been you know in
the same
room like far apart from one another
especially because trump now
now no longer transmits the disease we
now know that he's had at least two
negative tests this week
we know that he was not going to
transmit it to joe biden in fact of all
human beings on planet earth
the person who is least likely to
transmit this disease to joe biden at
this point is donald trump because he
has now had it
and he is no longer transmitting it
according to his own doctors
doesn't matter commission on
presidential debate killed the debate so
instead we have these dueling town halls
again an indicator of bias here steve
scully was supposed to be
the actual moderator in that debate and
steve scully of c-span was supposed to
be the moderator
he was suspended from c-span last night
the reason that he was suspended is
because he lied about his twitter
account being hacked
you'll recall that the washington
journal host went viral last week after
a tweet sent from his account
indicated that he'd reached out to
anthony scaramucci for advice
and then he claimed that he was hacked
he had not in fact reached out to
anthony scaramucci for advice it turns
out that in the past whenever
he tweets something bad he claims he is
hacked a la joy reid on msnbc
well now the the c-span administration
has decided to suspend him
without pay scully wrote for several
weeks i was subjected to relentless
criticism on social media
and in conservative news outlets
regarding my role as moderator for the
second presidential debate including
attacks aimed at directly at my family
this culminated on thursday october 8th
when i heard president trump go on
national television twice and falsely
attacked me by name
out of frustration i sent a brief tweet
addressed to anthony scaramucci the next
morning when i saw the tweet had created
a controversy i falsely claimed my
twitter account had been hacked
these were both errors in judgment for
which i am totally responsible i
apologize
c-span issued a statement revealing that
the network and the commission on
presidential debates were made aware
about scully's fabrication on wednesday
they said we are very saddened by this
news and do not condone his actions
starting immediately we have placed
steve on administrative leave after some
distance from this episode we believe in
his ability to continue to contribute
to c-span president trump immediately
went on twitter and tweeted about it of
course he said i was right again
steve scully just admitted he was lying
about his twitter being hacked the
debate was rigged
he was suspended from c-span
indefinitely the trump campaign was not
treated fairly by the commission
did i show good instincts and being the
first to know that
it's so typically trumpian and i was the
first i said it
was high okay so steve scully was
suspended and then in the lead up
to the debates we had input in which
many members of the media were very
angry that nbc would even allow
some sort of town hall with the sitting
president of the united states how
dare nbc this was supposed to be joe
biden's night
it was donald trump who pulled out of
that zoom debate now it turns out that
donald trump was totally justified in
pulling out of the zoom debate because
donald trump has been doing rallies
donald trump is healthy now
okay but doesn't matter members of the
press were fighting mad
how could nbc counter program joe biden
with donald trump
i mean joe biden's a good person and
donald trump's a bad person we should
never let nbc news
ask tough questions of donald trump so
it was pretty obvious where this was
going from the outset right as soon as
nbc news started getting
pressure it was fairly obvious they were
going to go to somebody like savannah
guthrie and say okay we want you to grow
the living hell
out of trump i mean we want this guy
well done the entire hollywood
infrastructure
mobilized to tell nbc news how bad they
were
according to the hollywood reporter jj
abrams anna duvernay and marissa
hargitay were among 100 top hollywood
players protesting at nbc's trump town
hall i noticed none of them
decided to forfeit their pay from nbc if
they work for nbc
according to the hollywood reporter the
group wrote you are enabling the
president's bad behavior while
undercutting the presidential debate
commission and doing disservice to the
american public
more than 100 top showrunners producers
and stars have sent a petition to
comcast and nbc universal executives
protesting the timing of tonight's town
hall with president donald trump
wow the list of heavyweights who signed
the letter of protest includes
j.j abrams law order svu star mariska
hargitay
this is us creator dan fogelman and eva
duvernay
wow you mean hollywood celebrities don't
like a thing that's happening so they
wrote a letter
the stunning bravery oh my goodness
speaking of stunning bravery later on in
the show we're going to deconstruct some
culture
because demi lovato has put out a piece
of unbelievably
incomparably stunning bravery the
amazing stunning bravery of people in
hollywood
to signal that they don't like donald
trump i mean my god listen the career
risk
it requires in hollywood to say that you
don't like the orange man bad
my these people should all be given
congressional medals of honor
these people they're like the people who
walked who stormed the beaches of
normandy
they wrote a letter to nbc universal
saying that they're big mads
and they have this ads about donald
trump being on nbc answering questions
from savannah guthrie
oh the bravery oh the unbelievable
courage
it's honestly it's just as an american
i'm just proud of them
fireworks going off screeching eagle
blue angels
do it man this is america and our
hollywood bettors
they know that we should never ever
allow the sitting president of the
united states to do a tale
a town hall on network news that's bad
and and again risky stuff i mean this is
just like going up against joe mccarthy
in the 1950s
this is this is what a moment what a big
moment for hollywood
standing up against the throngs about
people in their industry who love donald
trump
frankly i can't believe it i just i
cannot believe the
incredible courageous bravery of
stunningness and stunning courageous
bravery i'm seeing right now
the petition was sent to comcast ceo
brian roberts nbc universal chairman
jeff shell and nbc universal news group
chairman cesar conde told the executives
quote you are enabling the president's
bad behavior they continue this is not a
partisan issue
this is about the political health of
our democracy oh it's not a partisan
issue is it
because uh any of those people on that
list republicans like
any like one any no no
bueller bueller the group includes such
top nbc talent as chris maloney
and this is us star sterling k brown as
well as heavyweights aaron sorkin greg
berlanti ryan murphy and seth macfarlane
wow with a list of diverse political
people like that
i mean that is clearly a bipartisan
letter
how dare nbc provide
a forum for donald trump nbc provided a
statement from dr h clifford layne
clinical director of the national
institutes of
national institutes of health in which
he said that he and dr anthony fauci had
reviewed at trump's medical data and
concluded with a high degree of
conference the president was not
shedding an infectious virus
nbc had said it would not rely solely on
trump's doctor's word
even before the petition was drafted
numerous current and former nbc
universal staff members had expressed
anger and disdain
for the network's decision to schedule
trump's events at the same time as abc's
event with biden
i don't think many of us are proud of
this moment one current nbc exec told
thr
i love that that's that's true bravery
is that not only are you quoted opposing
a thing about donald trump
you do so anonymously that that's big
big braves wow former nbc executive
vivian schiller tweeted the point of a
news organization is to serve the public
this is the opposite nbc news could
literally run this any other day or any
other time
shameful former nbc anchor katie couric
also tweeted this is a bad decision
wow amazing amazing
they wrote we believe this kind of
indifference to the norms and rules of
our democracy i would have brought our
country to this parallel state okay i'm
just going to point out
that um if we're talking about
indifference to the norms and rules of
our democracy
you literally are backing a candidate
who will not answer whether he pledges
to kill the supreme court
by packing it kill the filibuster pack
the senate with additional states
you believe that constitutional freedoms
ought to be overridden at the behest of
a bare majority of social liberals
so um yeah don't lecture me on norms and
decency when you're talking about
whether the president should be able to
answer questions on nbc news come the
hell on
absurdity absurdity at the highest level
but you know what adam scott
signed this letter i mean come on so did
billy eichner i mean if billy agner
signed a letter it billy billy porter
i mean saint god billy porter signed a
letter
the guy who appeared at the dnc it's
nonpartisan guys
super duper nonpartisan well done
everybody i mean jon hamm signed this
letter
i'm amazed kumail nanjiani signed this
patton oswalt the voice of the rat from
ratatouille signed this letter if
if the voice if seth rogen signed this
letter a dude who hasn't been
who hasn't been not high for more than
30 seconds in the past 25 years signed
this letter
i'm on board i'm on board what what a
convincing
show alec baldwin signed it mike can you
get more informed on politics than alec
baldwin
okay so all of this was the lead up to
the the nbc news interview with trump
which of course
the ratings are coming in it would be a
shock if trump did not get better bigger
ratings
than joe biden but that really doesn't
matter all this was the lead up
to what the onus was going to be for
savannah guthrie
and the onus was going to be on her to
be extremely mean
to trump right it wasn't going to be an
honest question answer session it was
going to be
so mr orange man how orange are you
orange bad man how bad are you orange
bad fat man
how fat are you and that was basically
that was in fact the tone and tenor of
this entire thing we'll get to that in
just one second first
as you may have noticed folks we are
just weeks away from a crucial election
whether you are invested in the
presidential election whether you're
invested in a senate race if you're a
conservative you need to get out there
you need to get active and this means
you need to go right now to
keepamericaamerica.com we are watching
record
turnout particularly for democrats in a
lot of areas across the country
republicans better get their game going
right now if you live in ohio
early in person voting has already
started arizona michigan
these are all swing states okay these
are states where conservatives need to
show up
and that's why i need you to go to
keepamericamerica.com right now they'll
get you the most trusted up-to-date
voting information and while you're
there please commit to take one person
to the polls
just one or help them complete a mail-in
ballot the 2016 election was decided by
thousands of votes
not millions the swing states are still
extremely close no matter what the
national polling says
350 000 of you across the country have
already gone to keepamericamerica.com i
want to see that number reach a million
or more
make this the biggest get out the vote
effort in conservative history when the
left-wing media cannot ignore do a
little
do a lot do your part this election is
going to have tremendous ramifications
for how you live your life particularly
if the democrats were to take the
presidency and the senate
things can go wildly wrong really
quickly go to keepamericamerica.com and
do your part right now keep america
america.com okay so all the pressure was
on nbc news last night to be very very
mean to trump and trump predicted this
right trump came out
it was perfectly obvious this is how it
was gonna go trump came out and uh and
he suggested
that the only reason he was gonna do the
town hall was because it represented
a free hour of television and he said i
know i'm walking
into basically an ambush he said that
i'm doing
this this town hall on behalf of concast
c-o-n because it's a big con so trump
knew exactly what this was going to be
before
he walked in and i will say that overall
i thought that trump handled himself
fairly decently
his big problem is that trump creates
obstacles for himself that he then
cannot overcome right he retweets dumb
crap
and then when he's asked about the dumb
crap he feels the necessity to double
down on the dumb crap
but was he really being asked serious
questions it was
i would take half of savannah guthrie's
questions last night or about
bad things trump has tweeted and the
other half were about why trump is so
bad on covet
so savannah guthrie interrupted trump
she had exchanges with trump from 25
times
last night according to account from the
media research center as opposed to joe
biden
who was interviewed by a very friendly
george stephanopoulos who basically
got out the uh massage oils and went to
work on slojo
he he allowed joe to to not only speak
but speak at length
he asked him very non-difficult
questions
for joe biden he didn't interrupt him
nearly at all that was not the tenor for
savannah guthrie producer colton was
watching this in real time
and he was flipping back and forth he
told me this morning that if you wanted
to back the narrative that trump has
created and and has pointed out about
the media disparity all you had to do
was flip channels
because on one channel you were watching
joe biden have a cup of tea with george
stephanopoulos former clinton staffer
stephanopoulos
and on the other channel you were
watching savannah guthrie take out
the old style 1960s paddle and just
whack trump with it
so here was savannah guthrie who earned
herself a spot in the
in the biden administration and now the
media are just reveling in this i mean
they
love it because this was the mandate
right the mandate was she had to be mean
to trump and she was mean to trump
so here is how variety describes
savannah guthrie's performance of course
because it's not about
getting information to the american
public it is about how the anchors
perform
under pressure to be mean to the bad
orange man who is orange bad and fat
here is variety quote president trump
wanted to run and ramble savannah
guthrie wouldn't let him
now let's just point out that joe biden
has been running and rambling running
from cameras
and rambling throughout this entire
campaign and the media have absolutely
let him do it
but according to variety it was savannah
guthrie
she pinned trump down and what may be
the performance of a career
uh okay so first of all the fact that we
are now describing news anchors as
performers
is kind of gross right normally when you
have news anchors asking questions it
shouldn't be
oh they're performing it was like that
that quote performance of a career could
describe
both glenn close in the new hillbilly
elegy trailer and also savannah guthrie
in this town hall with trump in what may
be the performance of a career
the popular today anchor kept a tight
reign on the proceedings of a
controversial town hall event in miami
with president trump that put the
network's parents nbc universal
in the crosshairs of critics and
hollywood a-listers
many consumers have rebuked nbc for its
decision to put trump opposite a similar
discussion his democratic challenger joe
biden had with abc news and george
stephanopoulos
at the same time okay so again the left
creates a controversy and then off the
back of that controversy
they demand they demand that the
the nbc news anchors perform
as brutally to trump as possible for
just under 60 minutes on nbc guthrie
held trump to account
asking him if he had in fact contracted
pneumonia while infected why he had a
problem making a definite
a definitive dismissal of white
supremacy telling him he had no legal
defense against the release of his much
sought-after tax returns
asking him to denounce conspiracy
theories held by some of his backers
she kept the president to short answers
and after he responded to various
citizens in place
to ask him questions added fact checks
and follow-ups even close observers of
the news industry
and the current outrageous political
psychology gave her kudos
i'm impressed with guthrie's
preparedness so far she's been ready for
some of trump's regular false claims to
daniel dale
the cnn fact-checking correspondent via
twitter daniel dale has reached
new levels of prominence because he does
these sort of fact checks where he takes
everything that trump says and then like
down to my nudist detail
fact checks them while doing nothing
similar to joe biden daniel dale has
been a partisan actor
he was further i think with the toronto
star where he accused me of being
responsible for mass shooting so he is
really a fact-checking dude
daniel dale anyway let's show you some
of savannah guthrie because the story
last night was not trump
right i thought again when trump was
asked an honest question and allowed to
answer it i thought he handled himself
fairly decently the biggest problems for
trump were once again
the man's twitter finger is extremely
extremely fast right he's got that hair
trigger twitter finger
and he fires off these tweets without
thinking about them and then he's asked
about them and because trump has no
oops in his body he decides that he is
going to double down on them those were
the worst moments for him
but the real story of the night was
indeed savannah guthrie showing her
journalistic bona fides by harassing the
president
okay so here she was debating trump on
mass scoring and it really was a debate
i mean as the trump pence campaign the
trump pens campaign put out a statement
they said
even though the commission canceled the
in-person debate that could have
happened tonight one occurred anyway
and president trump soundly defeated
nbc's savannah guthrie in her role as
debate opponents and joe biden surrogate
president trump masterfully handled
guthrie's attacks and interacted warmly
and effectively with voters in the room
over on nbc it was a completely
different scene as once again biden was
kept comfortable and away from any
questions that might challenge him
americans can see that president trump
is leading the country et cetera et
cetera et cetera it's tim murtagh the
trump 2020 communications director
whatever you think of trump's
performance
the characterization of how the media
treat the two candidates is obviously
true
here is you'll see the compare and
contrast here here's savannah guthrie
debating trump on mask wearing
if everyone wore a mask you could cut
expected deaths
in half 60 000 well what is that
if you look at scott dr scott he's from
great guy
stanford he will tell you he's not an
infectious disease expert
oh i don't know look he's an expert he's
one of the great experts in the world
i don't get it because you have so much
power and influence as president
you could go to your you can require it
in your rallies and you should say
everyone put on a mask right now and the
university of washington says you could
say
washington and you have other places to
say different things okay so again
that is not savannah guthrie asking a
question that is savannah guthrie
talking over him and not allowing him to
answer
the question and by the way there are a
good number of doctors including doctors
for the greater barrington declaration
which is now being
which is now being basically suppressed
by social media the great barrington
declaration essentially suggests that if
you are young and healthy
then you should be pursuing herd
immunity right if you're 20 years old
then you probably shouldn't be wearing a
mask as long as you stay away from
people who are older and vulnerable
and when trump says that there's still
controversy over masking there is
controversy over masking in northern
europe
a lot of countries don't mask
scandinavia does not mask okay that
doesn't mean
that we shouldn't ask when we're in
close quarters particularly with elderly
and vulnerable people
again i think that there's a fairly
clear standard here if you're alone on a
beach you shouldn't mask i don't think
that three-year-old children should be
masking my son is going to school right
now he is four they are making him wear
a mask i think it's absurd
i think that that four-year-old's
masking is ridiculous i don't think they
can properly wear masks
i think even if they do properly wear
masks they're not at grave risk from
this virus i think if a four-year-old is
in
close coordination with a 65 year old
that is a different story
okay that is what the science tends to
show because again if a four-year-old
gets covered
four-year-old is fine if a 65-year-old
or a seven-year-old gets coveted
math changes hey with all of that said
that that's savannah guthrie debating
trump that is not savannah guthrie
asking trump
a question okay and it was like this all
night so she badgered him
about voter fraud right trump has said
that there could be widespread voter
fraud
and she said well no no there's no
widespread voter fraud he said right
there could be the possibility of
widespread voter fraud and we should be
aware of that
and she just was not having any of it
there is in fact
no evidence of widespread fraud and you
were so in doubt about our democracy our
democracy
how can you say that you do read
newspapers you do watch the news i know
you read this
but you watch it i do because every day
they're talking about
ballots that are corrupt that are
fraudulent and millions that are
being processed right now but you can
win a race take a look at me
you can win a race by one percent but
why are you laying the groundwork for
that right now it's like if i don't want
to
say my husband and i say my ankles i
don't want that to happen
okay well what is she even talking about
tennis and her husband her ankle and all
this
this was not a question right she wasn't
asking him a question and then
letting him answer the question and then
hitting him with follow-up she was just
lecturing him which is what members of
the media and hollywood wanted her to do
the i thought the worst exchange for
guthrie was clearly on white supremacy
clearly so so democrats the media
they've had this this lie that they've
been promoting for years which is that
trump is actually white supremacist that
covertly he's a white supremacist he
likes white supremacists
okay that is a lie even in
charlottesville where i harangued him
for not being fast enough to condemn
white supremacists and the first day
because he said there were many people
there with many different views on the
first day and then he corrected it
and then in that second statement which
happened on saturday he overtly said
when he was talking about quote-unquote
good people
he said i am not talking about the
neo-nazis i am not talking about the
white supremacists
who should be thoroughly condemned that
is a direct quote okay that that
or at least a very close paraphrase
the media have never let go with his
bone and so they have been asking him in
every single
interview to condemn white supremacy and
he in every single interview does
and then they go right but you won't and
he's like but i just did they're like
bobby you're not
he's like but but i but i am like yeah
but you're not right now and he's like
oh but i am condemning it right now like
ah but when you said that that was one
second ago that's now in the past
so will you do it right now he's like
absolutely i can then white supremacy
and they're like yeah but that was now
three seconds ago when i'm asking you
this question
so i'm going to do it again right now
because every second that passes
means that what you said is in the past
so i don't believe you anymore what are
you doing right now
that's that's pretty much how this
debate with savannah guthrie one it was
pretty absurd we'll get to that
in just one second first let us talk
about
the fact that some of your employees you
know they might need to be replaced
and some of your employees might really
need some work
so you know we have employees at the
daily wire
who let's just say that that
when they hook up with somebody via
skype
on a zoom call these employees may see
some things
that uh that they then convey to the
rest of the staff
when when the reality is that this
creates a bit of a problem for the rest
of the staff because now they've been
subjected to
the stories being told by this
particular employee we'll call him nick
and let's say that you know you kind of
want a memory hole nick
and so what you decide to do is replace
nick via zip recruiter
zip recruiter will send your job to over
100 of the web's leading job sites they
don't stop there with their powerful
matching technology zip recruiter scans
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right experience
and then actively invites them to apply
to your job zip recruiter makes hiring
efficient and effective with features
like screening questions to filter
candidates and an all-in-one dashboard
where you can review and rate your
candidates zip recruiter is so effective
that four out of five employers who post
unzip recruiter get a quality candidate
within
the very first day right now to try zip
recruiter for free my listeners can go
to ziprecruiter.com
dailywire at ziprecruiter.com slash
daily wire zip recruiter.com
dailywear and by the way if you're
looking for a job zip recruit is a great
place to start
ziprecruiter is indeed the smartest way
to hire ziprecruiter.com
dailywire to get started okay so the
worst exchange for guthrie and this of
course was one the media celebrated most
was savannah guthrie going after trump
on white supremacy
again trump has condemned this thing
like 1 000 times and every exchange
about white supremacy goes the same way
will you condemn white supremacy
sure then do it i just did do it now
okay i can white supremacy why aren't
you more enthusiastic about your
condemnation
okay this is just this exchange was
particularly bad savannah guthrie of
course got kudos from the rest of the
media she's
her star is rising guys because remember
opposing trump is stunning and brave
so if you oppose trump it's stunning and
brave and you're really risking
everything
like possibly a giant raise or you know
a move into like that 60 minutes rule
i mean these are serious career risks
that you take when you are mean to
president trump
here is here's savannah guthrie asking
trump about white supremacy for the 1
millionth time
i denounce white supremacy okay
white supremacy for years but you always
do it you always start off with the
question you didn't ask jill biden
whether or not he denounces antifa
i watched him in the same basic show
with lester holt
and he was asking questions like biden
was a child well
well so this is a little bit of a job
are you listening
i denounce white supremacy what's your
next question do you feel
it feels sometimes you're hesitant to do
so like you waited here we go again
every time in fact my people came i'm
sure they'll ask you the white supremacy
question
i denounce white supremacy he
okay that again that exchange is amazing
she's like i didn't announce white
supremacy like but were you enthusiastic
enough he's like yeah but i just did
you know you should why i want my
opponents can them antifa or black lives
matter
they won't do that he's like yeah but
you won't denounce your premises like i
literally just
did i mean this was jordan peterson and
kathy newman right you remember that
jordan peterson kathy newman interview
where she was like so you hate women
he's like no
i really don't you know i really don't i
don't i no
no and
it was that right do you contemplate
sure
of course but how enthusiastically
are you gonna go out there and like help
me hunt down the kkk
and what do you think donald let's go
out there and do it now you willing to
do that like what are you
okay so guthrie was bad
that said and trump had some good
moments i mean there were people who
asked him kind of funny questions one
lady got up and told him he was very
handsome and
you could see trump glowing from the
inside it was pretty wild um but
the uh there were a couple of moments
that were just bad for trump and the
reason they were bad for trump and these
are the ones that will of course go
viral
is because trump makes trouble for
himself on twitter twitter is very bad
for trump
i know everybody hates when i say this
it happens to be true
if donald trump had dropped his phone in
a toilet on january 21
2017 he would be up in the polls by five
points right now
no one needs a window into trump's mind
it's kind of a crazy place
and the fact that trump tweets out crazy
things and retweets crazy things
and then he's asked questions about them
and then his natural instinct is to
defend the crazy thing that he tweeted
is not particularly a good look i mean
today how bad is twitter for trump today
donald trump went on twitter there was a
piece from our friends over
at the at the babylon b okay and this
piece over at the babylon b
suggest so twitter had an outage
yesterday for like 90 minutes twitter
was just completely down
and trump and the babylon b wrote a
piece
making fun of twitter right saying that
twitter had shut down
all of twitter in order to stop trump
right that is obviously making a joke
about the fact that twitter shut down
this new york post story
in order to in order to stop trump right
that
that was the joke trump immediately
tweeted out
that this was a real story right trump
that the that twitter actually had done
this
that big t meaning twitter had done this
twitter shuts down entire network too
slow spread of negative biden news wow
this has never been done in history this
includes his really bad interview last
night why is twitter doing this
bringing more attention to sleepy joe
and big t
um so what he said that big t was not a
reference to me it was rather a
reference to big tech
which should have been properly pointed
out in twitter's fake trending section
does any of this help i mean that is
okay so
that's just a dumb thing that trump
tweeted today those kinds of things
they allow the media to avoid focusing
in on joe biden which is what trump
needs if he wishes to win
so guthrie focused in on trump's tweets
because this is the easiest way to do a
negative interview
interview with trump is to point out the
fact that the guy tweets on the toilet
all day long and that he tweets some
dumb things so here she was going after
trump on queueing on
do you think that trump has great
familiarity with kunan like this is a
pretty easy answer
is the truth he should just say q and on
stupid this is garbage
but trump will never do that if the
media prompt him to do a thing he won't
do it to understand donald trump as a
human being all you have to know
is that he was told not to look directly
into a solar eclipse so he took off his
glasses and looked directly into a solar
eclipse
i remember the picture right everybody
else was they had the glasses on so they
didn't damage their eyes i was like
oh look at me i'm superman check this
out
he just looks directly right that is
trump so if the media tell him anything
he will say precisely the opposite so if
the media are like
president trump there's a rumor online
that you
built the moon out of out of cow farts
you built it
like you make the parts material and you
built the moon out of cow farts there is
that rumor going around online will you
condemn that rumor trump like
i don't believe you and maybe i did i
don't know
i have to investigate my papa okay so
that's what happened with q and on last
night this of course is gonna be the
viral clip
making stepping on rakes is not a good
look this is not smart
now again several things can be true at
once savannah guthrie
can be a horrifyingly partisan
interviewer and also donald trump should
not have tweeted this stupid garbage and
then defended it so here was donald
trump defending
sort of kind of q anon sort of here was
it was trump going off on q and on which
by the way is like eight people
[Music]
in its entirety i know nothing about a q
anon
i just talked i know very little you
told me but what you tell me doesn't
necessarily make it fact i hate to say
that
republican senator ben sasse said quote
q anon
is nuts and real leaders call conspiracy
theories
conspiracy theories why not just say
it's crazy and not true he may be right
i just don't know about q anon
you do know i don't know no i don't know
okay so he says he doesn't know and it's
probably true i mean it's probably true
he doesn't sit around actually reading
the q and theories
all trump knows in politics is when
people like you then you just say nice
things about them this is true from kim
jong-un
to vladimir putin this has been trump's
mo forever if somebody says a nice thing
about him he immediately gives them the
benefit of the doubt because everything
is
refracted through the prism of trump's
ego every single thing in the world is
this is his big problem as a person it's
his big problem as a president
everything is refracted through the
prism of his own ego
it's true for barack obama too it's just
that trump is very he's much more gauche
about it
okay same kind of thing yesterday
trump retweeted a bizarre conspiracy
theory about how osama bin laden was not
actually killed on barack obama's orders
and it was all staged and crap like this
so so again this
surprised an easy avenue of attack for
savannah guthrie who went after trump on
this
why would you send a license
that was a retweet that was a an opinion
of somebody
and that was a retweet i'll put it out
there people can decide for themselves i
don't take a position it's not like
that was a retweet and i do a lot of
retweets and frankly
because the media is so fake and so
corrupt
if i didn't have social media i don't
call it twitter i call it social media
i wouldn't be able to get the word out
and the word
is insufficient okay it's true that he
uses twitter to get a message out the
messages he chooses to get out are very
often stupid so
savannah guthrie doing her best to
justify nbc news even holding this event
by
going after trump on issues small and
stupid
and really avoiding some of the larger
issues in the country right now
meanwhile
you flipped on over the channel and joe
biden was just sitting out there on a
hawaiian beach sipping a cocktail with
an umbrella in it
yeah basically just lounging around
having
somebody massage his weird hairy leg or
something
that that's what was going on over on
the other news network there's so much
noziness going on we'll get to that in
just one second first
let us talk about the fact that right
now things are wild out there we got
global pandemics civil unrest
politicians who are threatening to
infringe on your inalienable right to
defend yourself
emotions are running very high in the
country you see it on the news peaceful
protest turning violent riots in the
street
law enforcement not staffed to handle
all emergencies more and more
law-abiding americans are buying guns
like right now in fact
you may be one of the millions who've
recently purchased a gun for
self-defense now here's the question
are you prepared do you know how to use
it do you know under what circumstances
you can legally use it you need proper
education with a firearm you need
industry-leading training to ensure your
skills are sharp
when you are faced with danger and you
need the nation's best legal protection
should you god forbid find yourself lost
in the aftermath of a self-defense
incident you need my friends at us
concealed carry association get started
today by texting gun
to 87222 you'll receive the complete
concealed carry and family defense guide
for free
in this guide you'll learn how to detect
attackers before they see you how to
survive a mass shooting seven firearms
drills that could save your life and
much much more it is 164 pages it comes
with a bonus audio version so you can
listen
whenever you want in addition if you
text today you'll be entered to win a
thousand bucks to put toward a gun of
your choice that you can use to protect
your family text gun
gun to 87222 right now text gun to 87
222 right now to get started with my
friends over at the uscca an amazingly
good organization a really great
organization okay
meanwhile george stephanopoulos over on
abc was giving
joe biden a back rub the entire news
cycle over the last 48 hours has been
about this hunter biden story where it
turns out that hunter biden was
brokering influence in ukraine not a
single question from stephanopoulos
not one we got questions about every
other topic no real hard follow-ups but
not a single question about hunter biden
no no don't worry the media are
perfectly objective guys joe biden was
having the time of his life man
things were just going fantastically now
that doesn't mean that joe biden said
many coherent things
in fact joe biden said many things that
were um quite bizarre and some of them
were
quite radical he changed his positions
on some pretty core
issues so let's start with the bizarre
and the and the radical
so joe biden was specifically asked
about police action he has said this
stupid thing in the past and he said it
again last night
he suggested that we need to train the
police to shoot people in the leg
this is a talking point by morons this
is a talking point for people who don't
know anything about policing and don't
know anything about guns
this is not gene wilder in blazing
saddles guys
i mean first honestly if we're gonna do
this then really they shouldn't even
shoot the attacker in the leg what they
should do is shoot the
the gun or weapon out of an attacker's
hand
right that's really they should shoot
the trigger finger they should make it
so that you can't pull the trigger
finger like in the movies
this is what joe biden actually thinks
okay so the way that law enforcement
actually works
is that in the heat of the moment when
you have a just a split second to react
many of the shots go wild this is why
you are taught to fire until the threat
is neutralized
you are taught to fire at center of body
mass specifically because very often you
cannot aim
at a particular part of the body this
comes from somebody who obviously has
never really tried handling a handgun
and certainly not in a pressure
situation this idiotic notion you can
train police to shoot at limbs
is the stupidest garbage ever put forth
by people
who talk about guns so here's joe biden
he's done this multiple times and it's
amazing no one asks where's the
follow-up from george stephanopoulos
why is it that not a single police
department in america trains people to
shoot at limbs
because you cannot do that it does not
work here is joe biden laying this
fourth because he's an idiot
there's a lot of things we've learned
and it takes time but we can do this you
can ban
choke holes you can but but beyond that
you have to
teach people how to de-escalate
circumstances
de-escalate so instead of anybody coming
at you the first thing you do is shoot
to kill
you shoot them in a leg shoot them in
the leg
shoot them in the leg that's the instead
of shooting your kill shoot them in like
uh-huh
that's that's amazing i don't understand
why doesn't why don't the cops take out
a lightsaber
and just like you know melt the bullets
that are being shot at them
and then go over and disarm the person
by cutting off their arm like luke
skywalker
does or like obi-wan kenobi or something
in fact why doesn't why why don't the
cops just use wonder woman's lasso of
truth
and actually just like
this is a presidential candidate who's
supposed to be your serious presidential
candidate speaking of serious
presidential candidates
joe biden was asked once again on court
packing once again he declined to answer
joe he was not pressed by george
stephanopoulos he said don't worry i'll
tell you at some point
at some point you'll find out i mean
that point may never come
but sometime in the future i mean the
future is full of murkiness and
undecidedness so
at some point i'll probably tell you
here is joe biden not being asked a
difficult question
if they vote on it before the election
if they vote out before the election
you are open to expanding the court i'm
open to
considering what happens from that point
on
you know you said so many times during
the campaign all through the course of
your career it's important to level it
is but george
if i if i say no matter what answer i
gave you
if i say it that's the headline tomorrow
it won't be about what's going on now
the improper way they're proceeding but
don't voters have a right to know where
they do have a right to know what i
stand and i'll have a right to know
where i stand before they vote
so you'll come out with a clear position
before election day yes depending on how
they handle this
depending on how they handle this i love
that okay so what should george
stephanopoulos's answer there be
clearly if you were a journalist or if
you were going to savannah guthrie this
thing he would say okay why not right
now
like i'm looking at my watch here joe
and it turns out that today is
in fact october 15th and the election is
going to be held
in approximately two and a half weeks so
you're running out of time so why not do
it like right now
what's preventing you from doing it like
right now and instead joe biden's like
well you know i'm just not going to tell
you
everything's good and george stephen i
was like okay joe all right well fair
enough
not fair enough oh man okay
george stephanopoulos that's some harsh
questioning right there it shows you
the media standard for themself the
media's standard is that if you are
interviewing a republican you should act
like savannah guthrie and if you are if
you're interviewing joe biden you should
act like a doormat
that is the media double standard and
again that doesn't alleviate the fact
that trump handled some questions
badly last night and then he tweets dumb
crap these are separate issues
the media bias is very real there's a
reason conservatives distrust the media
there's a reason they distrust social
media they continue to promote
mainstream media
okay but back to biden so biden said
many many radical things
last night he said yesterday that small
children should be able to transition i
know that we're just going to gloss over
this thing
but this is insane this is insane so uh
a mother of a child
who believes that he is transgender an
eight-year-old eight years old gets up
and says
you know joe what are you gonna do for
kids like mine a boy who believes he's a
girl
who believes he is transgender and joe
biden says we should allow
eight-year-olds and ten-year-olds to
transition
those are children so he's talking about
right now
is allowing the treatment of a boy
as a girl not watchful waiting but an
eight-year-old says i think i'm a girl
today and that
kid is a boy and you say okay darling
and then you go out and buy
and you call them your daughter you
literally start treating the boy is a
girl
okay this is not best medical practice
there is not evidence to back that this
is a good idea
but this is the left propaganda which is
that you can identify
as a member of the opposite sex right
you can you can just pick your opposite
six at the age of eight
at the age of eight here's joe biden
spilling this one out there and he's
going to effectuate federal policy in
order to make this clear
so if you are a religious school for
example then he is going to make it
so that if a little boy comes in and he
now wants to identify as a little girl
and he wants to go to the girls school
right because in a lot of religious
communities you have a separate boy
school and a separate girls school
mainly because once they hit teenage
years you want to keep those kids
separated
okay but they have separate boys schools
and separate girls schools this is very
traditional in the religious community
it's very traditional in the jewish
community catholic community
evangelical protestant community that
joe biden will be the kind of person who
believes that you should be able to take
your boy and
enlist that kid in the girls school and
the school should simply deal with it
not only that he believe i mean on a
fundamental level believing that an
eight-year-old should be able to
transition his madness it's
absolute madness i wouldn't let my i
have a six-year-old i would not let her
choose
how to cut her own hair let alone how to
shape
her own sexual future that's insane and
the
uh it's it's crazy it's one thing you're
talking about a 20 year old it's an
it's another thing i mean there are
their problems too but if you're 20 at
least you have the ability to think
things through and consent if you're
eight you don't
but here's joe biden yesterday basically
standing up for the ability of
eight-year-olds to transition
the idea that an eight-year-old child or
a ten-year-old child decides
you know i decided i want to be
transgender that's what i think i'd like
to be
make my life a lot easier there should
be zero discrimination there is no
reason to suggest that there should be
any
right denied your daughter or daughters
whichever
one or two one one your daughter that
your other daughter has a right to be
and do
none zero okay it's not discrimination
to deny a boy access to a girl's locker
room
it is not discrimination to deny a boy
eight years old the ability to
hormonally transition
the hell is he talking about that is
radical stuff i know that the media
portrays this as mainstream
that is deeply radical and not only that
it will reach the
the point in american politics in very
very short order because you're already
seeing the early indicators
where if you as a parent say no to this
the government will
intervene and joe biden will back that
if you have an eight-year-old and your
eight-year-old goes to school your
eight-year-old boy goes to school
and he says to the teacher i feel like a
girl today and then the next day
your eight-year-old boy goes to school
he tells the teacher you know i went
home i told mommy i feel like a girl
and mommy said you're not a girl you're
a boy the teacher calls child protective
services
okay we are this far from that you watch
within the next five years this will
become rote
okay that that is something that that is
incredibly dangerous to children it's
incredibly dangerous to families
it's incredibly dangerous to basic human
reason what joe biden said there is
radical
it is radical and it is to say an
eight-year-old should be able to
transition
is is pretty horrifying on every
possible level okay but it's treated as
totally not only normal but sympathetic
and good
because eight-year-olds should be able
to make their own decisions on
everything including what sex they are
in contravention of reality all right
that is your moderate that is your
moderate candidate joe biden
okay then moderate joe biden also came
out and he said that he wanted to
encourage mask man
he he said he was asked about national
mass mandates now he has a problem
he cannot legally mandate a mask from
the from the top down you can't do that
at the national government level you
don't have the authority to do that so
we'll get to joe biden's answer on that
in just
one second first let us talk about the
fact that your sleep quality matters it
matters to me my kids wake me up at all
hours of the night in those brief
moments when i do get a chance to sleep
i need to be on a great mattress and
that is why i love helix sleep helix
sleep they've got a quiz it takes just
two minutes to complete they match your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
whether you're a side sleeper a hot
sleeper whether you like a plush or from
bed with helix there is no more
confusion and no more compromising helix
sleep is rated the number one mattress
by gq and wired magazine
cnn calls it the most comfortable
mattress they've ever slept on just go
to helixsleep.com
take their two minutes sleep quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that'll give you the best sleep of your
life they even have a 10-year warranty
you get to try it out for a hundred
nights risk-free they'll even pick it up
for you if you don't love it but you
absolutely will
sleep is very important to me it's
important my wife that's why we have our
personalized mattress from helix sleep
helix is offering up to 200 bucks off
all mattress orders for our listeners
get up to 200 bucks off at
helixsleep.com
that's helixsleep.com get a mattress
made
just for you because after all you are a
unique human and you require a unique
mattress go check them out right now
at helixsleep.com that's helix sleep.com
ben okay we'll get to more of this in
just one second first you don't want to
miss another great episode of the sunday
special coming up this weekend
we'll be joined by journalist megan
kelly to discuss the media bias against
trump
roger ailes in the movie bomb show why
she left fox and the real question
what is her take on her interaction with
trump during the 2016
20 2016 republican presidential campaign
so
go watch early over at dailywire.com or
listen this sunday on apple podcast
spotify
wherever else you get your podcast if
you want to see a bit of the trailer you
asked for it here it is
i'm worried about the kids who get this
the teenagers who get maligned as awful
bigots racists
xenophobes transphobes just for having
an opinion that
may not go with the you know the
mainstream now
how the media shames people out of an
honestly held or religiously held
opinion on controversial issues
and it's gonna get worse unless people
speak up
trump is shifting his campaign into high
gear these last few days before the
election ramping up all the big rallies
oh the rallies today at 3 45 pm eastern
12 45 pm pacific
michael moles will be hosting a live
watch party as part of a special edition
of all access
live head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe right now to get 20
off your all-access membership with
coupon code rally a daily wire
all-access membership it gives you
complete access to live online
discussions with our hosts over at
dailywire.com
as well as two leftist tears tumblers
and early sometimes exclusive access to
new deadly wire products
again that is dailywear.com subscribe
get 20
off and all access membership with
coupon code rally there's a limited time
offer so
act fast to join michael today
[Music]
okay so speaking of joe biden and his
answers so he was asked about masking
so trump was asked about masking why
don't you mandate masks why don't you
recommend masks
joe biden had said he would be in favor
of a national mass mandate then he
realized that you can't legally do that
so his solution is i'm going to ask
local mayors to tell people to mask
wow well if joe biden asks people
clearly they're going to do it clearly
they're going to get local mayors down
in the middle of texas who are like you
know joe biden called me i think i'm
gonna tell everybody that they are
forced by law to mask now
here was joe biden last night they can't
mandate a mask
but you can say you can go to every
governor and get them all in a room
all 50 of them as president say ask
people to wear the mask
everybody knows and if they don't they
don't no not fine then i go to every
governor i go to every mayor i go to
every council and i go to every local
official
say mandate the mask man say this is
what you have to do when you're out
make sure you encourage it being done
wow well you know that that
problem solved he's asking people to do
a thing incredible
incredible also he did change his
position on taxes so finally joe biden
recognized that saying that he was
willing to repeal trump's tax cuts
raises your taxes
which by the way fact checkers had said
was false right they said that if you
said that trump that biden repealing tax
cuts was going to raise your taxes
then that was fact check false it turns
out it was fact check true how do we
know because now biden is changing his
position
he says i'm not going to repeal all of
trump's tax cuts i'm only going to
repeal the tax cuts for the people who
earn the most
here's here was biden subtly changing
his position which nobody apparently
finds newsworthy
what is your plan for either extending
the tax cuts for the middle class or
creating a new plan that further reduces
those taxes
i carry this card with me when i said
the tax the
trump tax cuts about 1.3 trillion
of the two trillion dollars in his tax
cuts went to the top one tenth of one
percent
that's what i'm talking about
eliminating not all the tax cuts
that are out there oh is that oh because
you've said that you're gonna repeal
this from tax cuts so
now you're changing your position pretty
publicly okay just putting that out
there
apparently that is all that matters now
he's changed his position so i guess i
guess we're good now
finally joe biden concluded by saying
he's going to be a unifying president
which um comes as kind of a shock to
everybody who's watched joe biden across
the course of his career
a black voter asked him so you know you
keep saying things about race
i'm just wondering if you have anything
to appeal to black voters with other
than you're not black if you don't vote
for me
and here was biden's answer unless we
are able to treat people equally we're
not we're just
never going to meet our potential but i
think the american people want to see
that happen
i think they're ready to see it happen
and i'll tell you one thing if i'm
elected president
you will not hear me race paid you'll
not hear me dividing you hear me trying
to unify
and unify with bring people together
when i said i was running because i
wanted to unify the country people said
well there are the old days
we better be able to do it again we're
going to unify again says joe biden
a man who said that mitt romney is going
to put black people back in chains
yes i ju no one has been as unifying as
as joe biden over the course of his
career from a criminal justice to now
rejecting his own criminal justice in
from suggesting that america is
systemically racist to saying that
you're not black if you don't vote for
him
no one has done racial unity quite like
joe biden i mean what what a what a dude
what a stellar stellar dude
joe biden okay so that was the story of
last night
the story of last night was these
contrasts obviously there are contrasts
between
joe biden and how he acts and how donald
trump acts
and those were exacerbated last night by
the media coverage
but here's the thing no matter how the
election goes the media are going to be
with us
no matter how the election goes after
the election and the mask is off
the mask is completely off the media it
is very obvious exactly where they stand
there being clear and obvious about it
they recast their responsibility over
the course of trump's presidency they
used to say that we were here to provide
balance
then they decided it was false balance
to give any credibility at all to
conservative claims
that was false balance you see because
conservatism is false
therefore true balance is is just
butt wiping liberalism while hammering
conservatism that's real balance because
the facts require you
to yell at conservatives and to be super
nice to liberals that's what facts
require true balance
is not false balance true balance is you
ask hard questions to conservatives and
you ask easy questions to liberals and
that's what the media are here to do
to me that's a bigger and more
long-lasting issue than whatever happens
in the upcoming election
in early november okay so speaking of
that
speaking of issues that are going to
long outlast this election
we have to talk about the continuing
fallout from this social media debacle
so social media has stepped in it over
the last 48 hours
in an unprecedented way they decided to
ban the distribution of a new york post
story that they could not debunk
so there was this new york post story it
was hunter biden's emails come out
one of those emails suggested hunter
biden has brokered a meeting between a
barisma executive and joe biden joe
biden's people originally say it was not
officially on the calendar then later
they say okay
maybe there's a little bit of a meeting
now that doesn't mean that joe biden
shaped ukraine policy in order to
benefit his son bud
hunter it does mean that joe biden has
for years been looking the other way
while members of his family trade off
his name to make money
which is a tacit promise of some sort of
corrupt
relationship between biden and the rest
of his family
because if biden were truly going to be
the upstanding moral character
that he purports to be he would have
said to his family stop using my name in
order to make money by promising access
to me that i'm not going to give that's
not a moral thing to do
it may not be illegal for you to do what
you're doing but it is certainly corrupt
like joe biden so the media didn't like
this story and so they decided to quash
the story so twitter
put out a standard they said that we
don't want to put out the story at all
they blocked people from tweeting out
the url they blocked people's accounts
if they did tweet out the url and they
said they were doing this to prevent
unauthorized material from getting out
there which by the way is every single
news story
for the last 50 60 years it's an
unauthorized leak half of news is
unauthorized leaks so it's fairly
obvious what was going on
and the biden team used the twitter ban
as a point in favor of the falsity of
the story so look at the circular
reasoning here
a story comes out from the new york post
the biden team denies it
on the basis of the biden team denying
it purely on that based on nothing else
twitter and facebook decide that they're
going to restrict the distribution of
the story
then the biden team says hey look
twitter and facebook are restricting the
story it must be false
it's perfectly circular biden says it's
false twitter follows biden biden
follows twitter
it's unbelievable here was a biden press
secretary yesterday saying twitter
censored it so obviously it's false
i think twitter's response to the actual
uh
uh article itself uh makes clear that
these uh you know purported allegations
are false
uh and they're not true uh and glad to
hear you know to see
uh you know uh social media companies
like twitter taking responsibility to
limit misinformation
oh so now that now facebook and twitter
have declared it to not be worthy of
distribution
it's false now again nobody's actually
debunked any of the claims in the
article
nobody and mainstream media have not
done it they didn't wait to even have a
fact tracker look at it
that it but if by the way you think that
twitter
and facebook just killed the story on
their own
i have some doubts i would love to see
the call log between the heads of
facebook and twitter and the biden
campaign
you know that somebody dividing campaign
called them up and they were like this
story is false it's russian's
disinformation kill it
you know that's how this went you know
that it wasn't just twitter and facebook
on their own saying oh well you know
what i think i think that
we've got some problems with the story
how bad are our media
how truly awful are they at their jobs
so jake sherman
jake sherman of politico politico's
playbook he works for nbc news and msnbc
he issued an apology on twitter for
having tweeted the link
i'm not kidding now a normal
journalistic response to tweeting a link
from a mainstream paper like the new
york post
and then being banned for it or
suspended for it is what is this service
doing isn't this a crackdown on the free
press i'm told that every time trump
says something nasty about the press
that he is violating the rights of the
free press i keep hearing this over and
over and over
here you have actual journalists being
silenced on twitter
for tweeting out a link and the
journalists go on bended knee
and ask for forgiveness jake sherman
tweeted this i tweeted a link to the new
york post story right after it dropped
yesterday morning
i immediately reached out to the biden
campaign to see if they had any answer i
wish i had given the story a closer read
before tweeting it
twitter suspended me my goal is not to
spread information
my goal was to raise questions about the
story as i did in subsequent tweets and
see how the biden campaign was going to
respond
they later did respond my account is
clearly no longer suspended i deleted
the tweet
journalists deserve all the scoring they
receive seriously jake sherman is a top
journalist
he does some good reporting that's nuts
he tweeted out a link to another story
twitter suspended his accounts and he
apologized for having tweeted the link
imagine if this had come from the trump
administration
that jake sherman had put out a piece of
information and the trump administration
had done something in retaliation
that would be a violation of every first
amendment standard
now i understand the government is not
the same thing as twitter or facebook
but the fact that he is apologizing for
it is the problem right i'm not focusing
in
on the action so much as i am on the
reaction
you have social media actively telling
journalists they cannot tweet links
that twitter and facebook don't like and
journalists going oh well you know if
they say so and
if it was offensive to biden i guess i'm
i'm so sorry i'm so excited this is a
maoist struggle session on twitter and
frankly until he actually brings
some form of animal sacrifice in
penitence for what he has done here i
think it's completely insufficient
unless he does the work and does the
reading i think that jake sherman should
not be let back into the good halls of
society
it's amazing stuff okay all of this has
prom this isn't it's such a it's such a
self-own by the social media companies
because the only people who are out
there defending
the freedom of the social media
companies were people with conservatives
libertarian leanings like me
and you just cut out all the ground from
under us trump yesterday
suggested that section 230 of the
communications decency act should be
rewritten
to remove protections for companies like
twitter and facebook now i've been a
defender of section 230.
section 230 was originally written in
order to allow people to moderate their
comments the basic theory was this
you had a comment section on a site like
daily wire it was being
spammed with pornography or it was being
spammed
with garbage or abuse and now you could
remove all of that
content because before the idea was that
if you remove that content then you were
responsible for all the content in your
comment section because you were editing
it
and now you are legally liable in the
same way as if i hire a writer over at
daily wire
communications decency act section 230
says no you're not responsible for your
comments section but you can curate the
content
so that you don't end up with a trash
heap in your comment section we're not
going to punish you for making your
comment section
less garbage-y okay this has been used
by twitter and by facebook to curate
content
in a politically partisan way most
obviously this time
right most obviously this time and that
results in conservatives saying okay
well then maybe we should change section
230 i don't think there's a legislative
fix along
that particular line but there is an
attempt right now in congress
to curb section 230 in one particular
way that's not
completely objectionable here was trump
talking about section 230.
he and his family are crooked and they
were caught they got caught
now they're being protected by big tax
and a big tech persists in coordination
with the mainstream media
we must immediately strip them of their
section 230 protection
okay it's very simple okay so the
problem of course is that that gets rid
of any open thread
site where it gets word ready to get rid
of youtube it gets rid of our comment
section we'll just take down our comment
section or if we become liable for what
our commenters are saying
bite into the fact that if you curate
the comments
of a choice you can either curate or not
curate now and if you curry you're now
responsible for the comments
all commentary sections goes right this
is the big big problem there is one
proposal that's on the table
that seems a little bit better that is a
proposal to
change the standard in section 230 so
section 230 says no provider or user of
an interactive computer service shall be
held liable on account of any action
voluntarily taken in good faith
to restrict access to or availability of
material that the provider or user
considers to be obscene
lewd lascivious filthy excessively
violent harassing or otherwise
objectionable
it's the otherwise objectionable
phraseology that people are now looking
to change
because that's a catch-all right i think
we all agree if somebody's posting porn
in your comments you should be able to
remove it i think if somebody is posting
stuff that is obviously racist you
should be able to remove it if
somebody's harassing somebody in your
comments section you should be able to
remove it
but there is a case to be made that
otherwise objectionable is too broad
because it basically is a catch-all that
allows you to act as a publisher
by default right that you're now editing
your comments section to only allow
commentary from nbc news
right and so now you're basically
responsible for you're just a mirror of
nbc news
right that is the argument and it's it's
not a completely non-compelling argument
i think there is also a case
to strip liability protections for
fraudulent
for fraudulent implementation of your
own policies so in other words
you take down a story and you take down
a story it's not in good faith
it is possible there should be lawsuits
launched on the basis of the in good
faith standard
was this new york post story restricted
quote unquote in good faith
was that done in good faith it's very
difficult to see how that was done in
good faith maybe the new york post has a
lawsuit
under section 230 actually so we'll see
how all of that plays out bottom line is
this the social media companies just
shot themselves
directly in the foot like really really
in the foot
okay so it's time to do something that
we haven't done in a while it's one of
our most popular segments last time we
did this
we analyzed the glorious shakespearean
brilliant songwrap which was about
moisture states of genitals
and it was a very important statement
for feminists is what we learned we
learned that to criticize
that song meant that you were in some
way sexist
or that you were sexually starved in
some way we learned many things
actually in the course of of analyzing
that song well now
we have another glorious piece of
culture from the great artist demi
lovato
so demi lovato has put out a song the
song is titled commander in chief
how important is this song this song is
so important
so important she these 26 year old
singer shared a screenshot on her
instagram
stories of a comment she received after
releasing the music video
the comment written part i hope you
realize this makes people that don't
have the same political views
feel like they can't listen to you
anymore i'm personally ashamed to be a
levatic right now but no matter how hard
it is i'm not letting this song change
my feelings about you especially
after everything you've helped me with i
really hope this doesn't ruin your
career demetria
lovato shared her response in which she
stated she had a right to her own
political views
celebrities aren't just around to
entertain people for our entire lives i
mean literally you're an entertainer so
actually that's the part we care about
the most
to be honest with you just like my
plumber i mostly care about his plumbing
he has political views i mostly care
about the plumbing
lovato says i literally don't care if
this ruins my career
this isn't about that my career isn't
about that
as much as i would like to be sad that i
disappointed you i'm too busy being
bummed that you expect me
a queer hispanic woman to silence my
views and beliefs in order to please
my audience this is
i mentioned bravery earlier on the show
the stunning
stunning bravery both stunning and brave
how could it be so stunning and so brave
i mean it's just
frankly sometimes you're just in awe at
the bravery and the stunningness of the
stunning bravery
and this is one of those times a
hollywood starlet
a musical star in the hollywood
firmament
put out a song about how trump is bad
the and she i mean guys she doesn't care
if it ruins her career
the risk to her career is so grave right
now i mean i cannot think of a bigger
career risk
than being in an industry where
literally everyone wishes that trump
were dead
and you saying that you don't like trump
i cannot like the career risk there
is insane i cannot wait for demi
lovato's next song
i like gay marriage that's gonna be like
oh my god the career risk in hollywood
saying that she likes gay marriage
wow how about her next her album it
should be called
racism is bad and everybody be like oh
my god she said it
finally someone said it and the career
risk i mean my
if she says racism is bad man she's
taking her career
into her own hands amazing amazing stuff
like what wait wait hold up hold up what
if she sang a song
and the song wore the bible is wrong
i in hollywood wow the blowback the
blowback but she said something even
more controversial than any of those
things
donald trump is a mean bad orange man
who's fat orange and mean
and you are not allowed to say that in
hollywood she
i mean if you talk about somebody who's
really taken a risk somebody who's
really stepping out front willing to
take the slings and arrows of outrageous
fortune in order to defend a belief
system
that is deeply unpopular with her peers
it is demi lovato
in hollywood saying that donald trump is
a mean bad man
so she put out this this song it is
indeed
spectacular i mean it is somewhere i i
learned by the way i
i learned so many things during that rap
debacle i learned
that people on the left don't understand
basic humor so you could do like a full
10 minute segment
a laughing 10 minute segment about how
dumb the song is and uh you can
cynically analyze
the medical conditions necessary to have
to require a a bucket and a mop
and somehow people will take you
seriously if it serves their purposes to
do so
so i feel like we should really take
this as seriously as possible
okay i'm gonna try not to be sarcastic
or caustic in any way when i analyze
this song
commander in chief because i've learned
that people on the left have no sense of
humor at all
so we'll try to be deeply serious in in
our analysis of this i learned by the
way during that rap debacle
i learned that if you can not if you can
kind of rhyme words that are super
obscene
but not really rhyme them but kind of
come close like in the general
neighborhood where the vowels sound
similar they're not even like the same
vowels but like kind of similar
and if you can to make a music video
with liquid
with vaginal fluid flowing out the front
door
literally falling out the front door of
a of a home
if you do that it's just like the merry
wives of windsor by shakespeare
this is what this is what i learned i
learned that this was like a cross
between shakespeare
and beethoven that's what i learned so i
mean
our standards have been set quite high
here so we'll see if demi lovato can hit
those standards
here is demi lovato warbling commander
in chief
which i haven't i i'll be honest with
you i've only seen some of the lyrics i
haven't actually listened to the song
but i can guarantee you that because
it's so stunning and so brave it is also
artistically incredible
before i even listen to it i know i know
that it is a piece of artistic
genius i know that when we write the
list of songs
that aliens 1000 years from now will
look at when they when they try to
discern the best
of human civilization this will be up
there
it will be like beethoven's ninth
symphony it will be hamlet
and it will be demi lovato's
commander-in-chief i haven't even
listened to it yet but i know because of
the bravery because it is just so brave
so here's some bravery being super brave
courageously courageous stunning go
it's already great nothing's happened
yet but it's hard oh close-ups of people
close-ups of diverse people
were you ever taught when you were young
that that girl sounds just like demi
lovato if you mess with things
officially the boundary come under
[Music]
enough haven't they suffered enough
he's wearing a hat too and here's a guy
who apparently is sick
and she's also saying they also have the
same thing so personal gain fighting
fires with flyers and praying for
rain do you get off on pain we're
[Music]
do you even know the truth it's a bunch
of close-ups a moving close-up of gary
very diverse people of various weights
genders orientations
colors all singing the same song and lip
singing to let them know because all of
to us wow
this is so moving i mean you can tell
whenever there's the meaningful piano
chords underneath like imagine
that's how you know people are super
into it
i will say that it is it is kind of
weird when there are these like super
masculine men singing in demi lovato's
voice
it's a little weird but loud and proud
the best part of the song is that it
never exits a range of about five notes
[Music]
everyone is so sad in this video but i
get it i get why everybody is sad
[Music]
by the way most diverse casting call of
all time for this video
so very exciting stuff obviously and now
we're back to original girl
okay well that was fun i hope you
enjoyed that oh the camera's moving
again
oh and now we we've reached the
apotheosis
among the stars demi lovato singing
among the stars everybody else is
against a black background but demi
lovato is all of us she's like a
god-like figure
placed amongst the stars as we close in
on her face
she's also very upset demi lovato it
turns out
that she was like mr smith in the matrix
all the other figures were just
representations of mr smith
the matrix was everything all the other
groups here is the real human demi
lovato
and she's uh
okay so this is this is just it's grand
she's wow
okay this is the it's okay i couldn't do
it i'm sorry i tried to stay serious but
uh this is self parody
so i'm gonna read you the lyrics because
i was talking over some of them and i
think they deserve to be given their
full poetic respect
here is hear the lyrics ready were you
ever taught when you were young if you
mess with things selfishly they're bound
to come undone
i'm not the only one that's been
affected and resented every story you've
spun
and i'm a lucky one cause there are
people worse off that have suffered
enough
haven't they suffered enough but you
can't get enough of shutting down
systems for personal gain
fighting fires with flares and praying
for rain do you get off
on pain or not pawns in your game
commander-in-chief honestly if i did the
things you do i couldn't sleep
seriously do you even know the truth
we're in a state of crisis
people are dying while you line your
pockets deep commander-in-chief
how does it feel to still be able to
breathe
well that changes everything because
what i got there is a compelling case
that donald trump is a big meanie who
does mean things and is really mean
well mine mind blown
mind blown mind blown she explained to
cnn
we have to turn up and vote because it's
so important our voices are heard and
honestly for me whether you're a
republican or a democrat just get out
and vote no
i don't believe you i don't believe you
i don't think you want republicans
voting
she said that her inspiration for the
song was this there's been so many times
i've wanted to write the president a
letter or sit down with him and ask
these questions and then i thought
i don't really actually want to do that
yeah i know because you might get an
answer and i thought one way i could do
that is writing a song and releasing it
for the whole world to hear then he has
to answer those questions to everyone
and not just me oh oh
by by the way this song was co-written
with julia michaels justin transfer and
aaron canada this is one of the things
that i love most about our current
musical scene
is that it takes three it takes four
writers for that beethoven did all nine
of his symphonies by himself
shakespeare did all of his plays by
himself that took four writers
slow clap for the bravery and the
stunningness well done demi lovato
you've changed the world a
groundbreaking piece of culture that put
your entire career
at risk ah man wow that was
i i i there there are no more words
there are no more words there's only the
heartache
of knowing of knowing
okay i i know we're super long here but
i'm gonna do something that actually is
a bit of high culture it's called the
bible i know people on the left hate
this
uh on the far left and really there are
people on the left who actually don't
hate the bible but we have now begun
anew the book of genesis so every year
the the jews i know chris uh
andrew cuomo turn off turn off the show
right now andrew cuomo i said the jews
turn it off you two bill de blasio i
know they're very scary i'm gonna talk
some jew
okay so every year the jews we repeat
the cycle
of the first five books of moses all
right so we started that anew
this week the first part of the book of
genesis is of course the parsha of
brexit which is the creation of the
world
i want to focus in on what i think is
the single most important
story in human history i'm not talking
about the story of adam and eve and the
snake in the garden that one's real
important but
i'm talking about something else that is
indicative of all human relations
i'm talking about the story of cain and
abel so we're gonna give it a bit of a
close read right here because i think
that
in order to understand anything that
goes on with politics or human age you
have to understand
human beings have not changed human
nature has not changed this is why when
you see people on the left say things
like the constitution was written in
1787 and then it was
ratified in 1789 like what does that
have to do with us today human nature
didn't change human nature has not
changed for thousands of years
there is an innate human nature that
human nature tends towards sin
it also tends toward the ability for
greatness and that's the story of cain
and abel
in a nutshell so here is the story of
cain and abel it's really short
and it's incredibly meaningful it is
less than a chapter
and it essentially ends it's about 16
verses
so here we go now the man knew his wife
at eve this is adam and she conceived in
borkane
and she said i've acquired a man with
the lord and she continued to bear his
brother abel and abel was a shepherd of
flocks and cain was a tiller of the soil
so cain is agriculturalist now it came
to pass
at the end of days that cain brought the
fruit of the soil in offering to the
lord
and abel he too brought of the firstborn
of his flocks and of their fattest and
the lord turned to abel and to his
offering
okay so already we are faced with two
questions one cain seems like the good
guy here right
cain is the one who initiates the whole
i want to bring of my fruit to sacrifice
to god and express my gratitude it's
cain's idea not abels
and then god turns to abel not cain so
this brings the second question why is
cain
being ignored by god to cain in his
offering he did not turn it annoyed cain
exceedingly his countenance fell
and the lord said to kane why are you
annoyed and why has your countenance
fallen
is it not so that if you improve it will
be forgiven you if you do not improve
however at the entrance sin
is lying and to you is its longing but
you can rule over it
there's a beautiful section in john
steinbeck's east of eden it's all about
this
right the the word tim shaw that you can
rule over it that you have an evil
inclination and your job as a human
being is to learn to rule over that evil
inclination
so people for thousands of years have
talked about
the question why did god favor abel
over cain in this particular scenario
and it occurred to me reading it this
year
that god actually is not favoring abel
over cain
in accepting abel's offering it's not
really that that
god is doing something nice for abel
while doing something cruel to kane
he's actually doing something nice to
kane he's offering him
the opportunity to do what his parents
could not he's offering him the ability
to grow beyond himself
he's offering him the ability to repent
he's offering him the ability
to get better right god literally gives
him a lecture
and this is this is the divine speaking
to humankind and saying to all human
beings
sin lies at your door but you can rise
above it because you are better than
this
because you have the capacity to change
yourself you have the capacity
to make your own life better by
recognizing where you have failed and
then working
to rectify that breach right it's an
inspiring message
but cain takes it exactly like most
human beings take that message
which is he gets angry at reality he's
angry at reality
and he takes that anger out on abel cain
spoke to abel his brother we have no
idea what they said
right we have no it doesn't relate the
conversation it came to pass when they
were in the field that cain rose up
against abel his brother and slew him
and the lord said to cain where is abel
your brother okay so why is god playing
hide and seek with cain here god knows
exactly what happened he's god or he
does the same thing with adam
it's really interesting the parallelism
after the sin in the garden
god says to adam and eve what did you do
he knows what they did and they don't
fess up
instead adam blames even eve blames the
snake and so both of them are punished
so god is now giving cain
the same opportunity he's saying where
is abel your brother and what he wants
is for cain to confess he wants cain
even now to repent after killing his
brother
he wants cain to to repent and improve
every every moment you have before you
die is an opportunity to improve
and and cain said i do not know am i my
brother's keeper
and god said what have you done hark
your brother's blood cries
out to me from the earth which is some
of the most stirring language in all of
the bible
and now you're cursed even more than the
ground which opened its mouth to take
your brother's blood
from your hand when you till the soil it
will not continue to give its strength
to you you shall be a wanderer and an
exile
in the land okay and then cain said to
the lord is my iniquity
too great to bear so here's the part of
the story
that people tend to ignore cain gets the
message
cain actually gets the message right
because really he should die for having
committed murder
but king gets the message when he says
is my iniquity too great to bear
he's acknowledging for the first time
sin adam never really acknowledged that
he had sinned
even never early acknowledged that she
had sinned cain acknowledges that he
sins
right he uses the in hebrew it's biome
means so right avonie is my sin he's fir
is the first time in human history that
somebody is acknowledging a sin
he says behold you're driving me off the
face of the earth i shall be hidden from
before you i will be a wanderer and an
exile in the land it will be that
whoever finds me will kill me
now buried in that language is one
particular phrase that again gets
overlooked i shall be hidden from before
you
right mi paneka ester that before your
face i will be hidden
hey what he's longing for is that
connection with god anew
this is kane repenting so kane actually
does get the story of cain and abel
doesn't end with the killing
it ends with human beings realizing we
do have the capacity
to repent and what does god do the god
said god forgives him he says therefore
whoever kills cain
vengeance will be brought upon him at
sevenfold and the lord placed a mark on
cain that no one who find him slay him
so now god has placed its explicit
protection
on a murderer because the murderer
repented and cain went forth from before
the lord he dwelt in the land of
wanderers to the east of eden
came to his wife and then you get the
entire lineage of cade
and he goes and he uh he creates cities
right his children
create city create cities now what is
the purpose of having that story in
there
the story is not really about cain and
his descendants because they really
become irrelevant to the story of the
jewish people which follows in the five
books of moses
the story there is about humanity we all
have the capacity to recognize our own
sin
and to get better we all have the
capacity to recognize that we have done
evil things and to repent
we all have the obligation to recognize
our own sinful nature
and to work to move beyond it i've said
before something that sounds very harsh
for the vast majority of people if your
life sucks 90
of it is probably your fault this is
true for me it's true for everybody that
doesn't not 100
people have circumstances and for some
people 90
of their life sucking is not their fault
but for the vast majority of human
beings
your choice and your fate is in your
hands and that is the story of cain and
abel if you let jealousy overcome you
if you fight against the reality which
is that you have a sinful nature
is sometimes life ain't gonna go your
way and you need to change and adapt to
that reality
if you fight that then you end up being
condemned
if however you get the message team
shall if you rise above it
then you become a better a different
human being worthy of god's protection
alrighty i hope you have a wonderful
weekend we will be back here on monday
for more i'm ben shapiro this is the
bench hero show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wiedowsky our
associate producer is nick shien the
show is edited by adam syavette
audio mix by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
you know the matte wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about hope
you'll give it a listen